[Music]
talks to possibly bring the oakland a's
to las vegas hit a speed bump yeah after
an hours-long meeting tonight alameda
county voted in favor of a waterfront
ballpark district in the hopes of trying
to keep the team there sports director
chris matthews here in studio joining us
with more on where things go from here
chris yeah well thank you guys we've
been following those meetings for months
because the aides have been playing
vegas for months coming in and out of
town numerous times and feeding stories
to local media in hopes that oakland
city leaders would take notice well it
looks like they may have at least for
the time being after hours of discussion
the alameda county board of supervisors
voted 4-1
in favor of a non-binding vote that
allows the six million dollar baseball
project to move forward near the howard
terminal in oakland it's a vote that
says the city and county will work
together to provide millions in public
financing to fund a 35 000 seat ballpark
business complex hotel affordable
housing and union jobs basically this
vote keeps the project on the books